de este lado derecho tenemos un montón
de expresiones las cuales son
proporciones de las distinta información
dada por estos dos diagramas mientras
que aquí del lado izquierdo
tenemos el seno del ángulo en mecca j
el coseno del ángulo mkj y la tangente
de este ángulo mkj que por cierto si te
das cuenta el ángulo m kj nos estamos
refiriendo a este ángulo de aquí este
ángulo de aquí que se llama theta que
por cierto tiene la misma medida que
este ángulo theta entonces estos dos
ángulos tienen la misma medida y lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es ver cuál
de estas siguientes expresiones son
equivalentes a estas expresiones que
tengo aquí así que te voy a encargar que
pausas el vídeo justo ahorita e intente
resolverlo por ti mismo para ver si
llegamos a la misma solución
muy bien suponiendo que ya pausas de
justo ahora el vídeo
voy a intentar resolver este problema y
bueno cuando tú observas estos dos
diagramas el que tengo del lado
izquierdo tiene la intención de evocar
la definición de funciones
trigonométricas dadas por el círculo
unitario y bueno esto es porque bueno
aquí tenemos el círculo unitario
mientras que aquí del lado derecho
tenemos la intención de evocar las
definiciones del soca tohá porque el
justo aquí tenemos bueno pues la versión
más simple del triángulo rectángulo
ahora si nosotros recordamos la
definición del soca tohá porque de hecho
tengo el presentimiento que van a ser
bastante útiles recordando am el sol
ok quiere decir que el seno de un ángulo
es lo mismo que el opuesto entre la
hipotenusa el campo
y déjeme buscar este color el acá y acá
nos dice que el co seno de un cierto
ángulo es lo mismo que el adyacente
entre potencias y también tenemos el toa
el toa que nos dice todo lo que nos dice
que la tangente de un cierto ángulo es
lo mismo que el cateto puesto entre el
adyacente ok
así que nos podemos referir a esto o en
su dado caso podemos recordar las
definiciones de las funciones
trigonométricas dadas por el círculo
unitario es decir que el coche no de un
cierto ángulo el coseno un cierto ángulo
es la coordenada x del punto en donde
esta recta se intercepta con el círculo
unitario mientras que el seno del ángulo
lo podemos obtener con la coordenada de
tiempo de este punto en donde esta recta
intercepta al círculo unitario y de
hecho
algunos vídeos que es la definición
utilizando el círculo unitario es
solamente una extensión de la definición
del sujeto pero bueno vamos a ver
primero este caso x entre 1 x entre 1 y
bueno x es el valor de la primera
coordenada que tomamos en este punto de
qué otra manera x es la longitud de este
lado que tenemos aquí ok
x que por cierto relativo a este ángulo
theta que tenemos aquí x es el lado
adyacente x es el adyacente el adyacente
ok de lujo ahora y donde está el 1 bueno
si este es el círculo unitario entonces
su radio es 1 no es así este radio es 1
y por lo tanto si nos fijamos en este
triángulo rectángulo entonces uno es su
hipotenusa así que si aplicamos la
definición del soca tohá x / 1
lo mismo que el adyacente entre 1 que es
la hipotenusa déjame ponerlo uno que es
la hipotenusa ok y cuando me tomo el
adyacente entre la hipotenusa estoy
hablando del seno del coseno de este
ángulo theta así que déjame escribirlo x
entre 1 es exactamente lo mismo que el
coseno que el coseno del ángulo theta y
bueno habíamos dicho que si nos fijamos
en el coseno del ángulo mkj mkj estamos
refiriéndonos al ángulo teta porque
tienen la misma medida y por lo tanto el
concepto del ángulo mkj es exactamente
lo mismo que el coche no detecta que por
cierto estamos viendo que es lo mismo
que x entre 1 esto es exactamente lo
mismo que x entre 1
ok ahora movámonos allí entre 1 yen es
la longitud de este lado que tenemos
aquí de este lado que tenemos aquí lo
voy a poner con color azul que por
cierto es la segunda cordada de este
punto bien y bueno relativo este ángulo
theta que es el lado opuesto entonces lo
voy a poner aquí y es el opuesto y
cuando me fijo en la proporción y entre
1 me estoy refiriendo al opuesto entre
de puntos a lo cual es el seno
recordando la definición del sujeto a el
seno del ángulo teta es lo mismo que el
opuesto entre la hipotenusa y por lo
tanto ya lo puedo escribir aquí esto es
exactamente lo mismo que el seno del
ángulo theta ok y bueno habíamos dicho
que el ángulo mkj tiene la misma medida
que el ángulo theta por lo tanto esto es
lo mismo que el seno del ángulo theta
que acabamos de ver que es lo mismo que
yo
entre 1
ok ahora para estos dos resultados que
obtuvimos utilizando la definición del
shock ato am también podemos utilizar la
definición del círculo unitario porque x
entre 1 x entre 1 bueno pues esto es lo
mismo que x ok y x es la primera
coordenada de este punto que tenemos
aquí en donde se intersecta este lado
que forma a este ángulo o este rayo con
el círculo unitario que por definición
del círculo unitario es precisamente el
coseno de este ángulo x es el co seno de
este ángulo teta y por otra parte james
y si de aquí nosotros decimos que entre
1 es lo mismo que ya que es la segunda
coordenada de este punto
utilizando la definición del círculo
unitario estamos hablando del seno de
este ángulo de hecho podemos decir que
este punto es exactamente lo mismo que
tomarme el coseno de este ángulo de este
ángulo teta
en el seno de este ángulo theta ok esto
utilizando la definición de este círculo
trigonométrico pero bueno es hora de
movernos a este otro ejercicio la
siguiente proporción es x / yen lo cual
podemos decir que es lo mismo que x que
era el adyacente el adyacente entre ye
lo cual es el opuesto entre el opuesto y
si te das cuenta nuestra nuestra
definición del sujeto a la tangente es
el opuesto entre el adyacente y aquí
tenemos el adyacente entre el opuesto
eso quiere decir que es el recíproco de
la tangente y bueno si tenemos que
mencionar lo podríamos decir déjame
cambiar de color que esto es exactamente
lo mismo que 1
/ la tangente / la tangente de este
ángulo theta pero ya después
aprenderemos doble con tangente y todo
esto esencialmente no es una de nuestras
opciones y por lo tanto vamos a
cancelarlo porque no está en nuestras
opciones
ahora tenemos y / x lo cual si te das
cuenta es tomarme que que es el opuesto
relativo a este ángulo de tam y es el
lado opuesto relativo está en mundo te
está entre x que es el lado adyacente
relativo a este ángulo theta entre el
adyacente y bueno estás y están nuestras
definiciones del soca toa la tangente es
precisamente esto la tangente es el
opuesto entre la tea center y por lo
tanto podemos decir que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que la tangente de
éste
ángulo theta que por cierto habíamos
dicho que tiene la misma medida que este
ángulo mkj y por tanto ahora si puedo
decir que esto es lo mismo que la
tangente de este ángulo teta y esto es
lo mismo que hay que tomarnos gem entre
x ok vamos bien ahora trabajemos con
jota entre k jota entre can y ahora nos
estamos moviendo a este triángulo
rectángulo si te das cuenta j es
relativo a este ángulo theta el lado
adyacente este es el lado antecedente
mientras que camps relativo a este
ángulo theta que bueno es el ángulo que
nos importa que es el opuesto que es el
lado opuesto y bueno en este caso
tenemos cota entre camps lo cual es lo
mismo que el lado adyacente entre el
lado opuesto y otra vez si te das cuenta
es el recíproco de la tangente esto es
lo mismo que uno entre la tangente de
este ángulo teta pero no está entre
nuestras opciones y por lo tanto voy a
cancelar esta opción porque no está en
las respuestas que queremos
ahora tenemos acá entre j k / j lo cual
es el opuesto entre el adyacente el
opuesto entre adyacente que es lo mismo
que la tangente del ángulo teta la
tangente es el opuesto entre la presente
y entonces puede escribirlo aquí esto es
la tangente de este ángulo teta
y bueno la tangente de este ángulo teta
que habíamos dicho que es lo mismo que
la tangente del ángulo mkj y bueno esto
es lo mismo que entre x o cam cam / j ok
de lujo ahora vamos a m / j
/ j a que es igual y bueno m es la
hipotenusa la hipotenusa / la adyacente
a inscribirlo para que no se nos olvide
m es lo mismo que la hipotenusa la
hipotenusa en este triángulo rectángulo
relativo a este ángulo que tengo aquí y
ahora me quiero tomar el potes no usa
entre el adyacente y si te das cuenta
aquí tengo
el goce no el adyacente entre la
hipotenusa lo que no es lo mismo que la
hipotenusa entre la decente pero
entonces podemos construir que es el
recíproco del coseno esto es lo mismo
que uno entre el coseno de estambul o
teta pero como no está en mis opciones
entonces voy a cancelar esta proporción
esta proporción no está en las opciones
y ahora vamos al siguiente jota / m y si
te das cuenta tenemos el recíproco de
arriba jota entre m es lo mismo que
tomarme el adyacente entre la hipotenusa
y ese sí ésta es el coste de no justo de
eso estábamos hablando esto es lo mismo
que el seno de este ángulo teta ok y
entonces lo podemos poner aquí el coseno
estranguló teta que era lo mismo que el
co seno de este ángulo mkj que por
cierto era lo mismo que x entra uno es
también lo mismo que j&j entre / m
y ahora nos falta uno tenemos acá entre
m k / m lo cual es lo mismo que el
opuesto entre la hipotenusa el opuesto
entre la hipotenusa es lo cual es el
seno de este mundo te está el seno de
este ángulo teta que bueno habíamos
dicho que es lo mismo que el seno del
ángulo mkj y a todas estas expresiones
que tengo aquí y bueno vamos a ponerle
cam / m
y lo hemos logrado ya tenemos la
respuesta de este problema